russian military advances have stalled
but what comes next
western intelligence says vladimir putin
may not be fully informed by his own
intimidated military having misjudged
the resistance and resolve of the
ukrainians it all adds up to the
strategic miscalculation
that our leaders warned putin it would
be but history also suggests putin may
well carry on
years ago in chechnya russian troops
also suffered major setbacks this global
news report summed up western thinking
in 1999. the kremlin's initial boast
that victory in chechnya would be swift
and decisive is proving to be a costly
miscalculation it sounds familiar but
even then a young vladimir putin
dismissed international condemnation
the war in chechnya did not end for
another 10 years certainly when you look
at putin's
invasions you see this
reckless disregard for for human life
for civilian life the russians bombed
chechnya into submission the devastation
in the capital grosney the shell-shocked
civilians all acceptable to putin in
2016 russia's bombing campaign in aleppo
syria left utter destruction and
refugees defend for themselves what's
happening now in mariupol and other
ukrainian cities is not new it is
brutality we've seen before these are
the kinds of things that you learn that
you can bomb and use armor but it's not
as effective in ukraine when you're
dealing with a much larger country a
much more determined opposition with
much better weaponry when russia began
its invasion five weeks ago it already
controlled crimea and much of the
donbass region of ukraine since then the
russian military has gained control of
areas in the north close to kiev and
kharkiv and in the south creating a link
between the donbas and crimea that has
destroyed mariupol but ukrainian forces
are contesting many areas and while
russia has launched attacks all over the
country it is concentrated in the
eastern part of ukraine is that putin's
new plan whether he's actually pulling
back and going to say i'm just going to
focus on the dom boss and i'm not
worried about the rest of the country
i'm a skeptic mistrust for a leader who
in the past has met resistance with
deception and more firepower
eric sorensen global news toronto